Bei Mona Mittendrin weiss ich nie,
wo ich lande.
(Mal war ich im Gefängnis gelandet,
mal beim Schlagerfestival.)
(Von der Bühne)
Jetzt singen alle zusammen!
(Dieser Ort ist mir besonders
in Erinnerung geblieben.)
(Das Asylzentrum Biberhof
im Kanton Schwyz.)
(Drei Tage lebte ich dort.)
Das ist die Küche. Wichtig ist:
Wir schliessen sie über Nacht.
Sie ist von 7-22 Uhr geöffnet.
Der Kühlschrank ist hier.
Hallo!
14.3 -
das wird Ihr Kühlschrankfach sein.
Aha. Woah! Das ist wie ein
Schliessfach bei der Bank. - Ja.
Muss man die Dinge so einsperren?
- Ja.
Hier ist Ihr Zimmer.
Mit wie vielen?
- Sie sind zu viert.
Hallo.
- (Frauen) Hallo.
Ich mache etwas Licht.
- In einem Viererzimmer.
Ja, wir haben hier Viererzimmer.
* Mona lacht. *
Kommen Sie rein!
- Mona.
Yes, Mona, Mona, Mona.
- Mona, ja.
Dein Name?
- Sabeha.
Sabeha.
Hier ist alles, was Sie brauchen.
Duvet, Kissen ...
Die Dusche ist hier.
- Ja.
Seife müssen Sie selber kaufen.
- Okay.
Und, ja. Viel Glück!
(Das war vor knapp drei Jahren.)
(Ich bin in den Alltag
von Asylsuchenden getaucht.)
(Ein Alltag aus kochen,
putzen und warten.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Kinderlachen *
(Was ist aus den Menschen geworden,
die ich kennengelernt habe?)
(Aus Sabeha,
die ihre Liebsten so vermisste.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
(Jetzt treffe ich sie
im neuen Zuhause,
immer noch getrennt
von ihrer Familie.)
(Das wird sich
vermutlich nicht mehr ändern.)
Die Familie ist in Schweden.
- Ja.
Ich bin immer alleine hier.
(Auch in unserem Zimmer war Hind,
die in Syrien an der Uni arbeitete.)
Et la Suisse ...
(Wir konnten uns vor drei Jahren
nur auf Französisch unterhalten.)
(Inzwischen kann Hind gut Deutsch
und hat ein klares Ziel:)
Ich möchte gerne
eine Büroarbeit finden.
(Und Haleema Azimi und ihre Familie
aus Afghanistan.)
(Auch sie sind noch in der Schweiz.)
(Ihr Kopftuch hat sie
in der Zwischenzeit abgelegt.)
Ich habe gemerkt, dass viele Leute
das Kopftuch nicht mögen.
(Und schliesslich mein Putzkompagnon
Samsom, der mir stets voraus war.)
(Er schaffte, wovon viele
Asylbewerber nur träumen können.)
... Praktikum, also Arbeit.
Ich habe die Lehre erhalten.
Wow! Eine Lehrstelle.
(Vor drei Jahren haben wir uns
im Asylzentrum getroffen.)
(Wie sieht ihr Leben heute aus
und was sind ihre Träume?)
Dieser Frage ich gehe nach:
"Mona mittendrin -  Update".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Angespannt-pulsierende Musik *
(Kurz vor 7 Uhr in Unteriberg
im Kanton Schwyz.)
(Nicht nur das Zuhause
von Wendy Holdener,
neuerdings auch von Familie Azimi.)
* Summton *
Guten Morgen!
- Guten Morgen!
Guten Morgen. Willkommen,
bitte schön. - Vielen Dank.
Hoi!
Hoi, hoi. Muska.
Hoi, hoi.
Wie geht's?
Und das ist der kleine Vali.
Hoi, Vali.
(Ich werde
mit offenen Armen empfangen,
mit einem üppigen Frühstücksbüffet,
alles von Mutter Haleema gebacken.)
Was ist für dich einfacher?
Soll ich Hochdeutsch
mit dir sprechen oder Mundart?
Ähm ...
Hochdeutsch.
Das ist super.
Es ist schön, euch hier zu sehen.
- Ich bin auch sehr froh.
(Azimis sind glücklich,
dass sie nach acht Monaten
im Durchgangszentrum
in eine eigene Wohnung
ziehen konnten.)
(Den Ort konnten sie nicht
auswählen, man wird zugeteilt.)
Habt ihr Unteriberg vorher gekannt?
Nein.
- Nie gehört.
Wir haben auf der Map ...
- ... auf der Karte geschaut.
Wo? Und dann: "Ah, das ist so."
(Von der Millionenstadt Kabul
ins Bergdorf Unteriberg.)
(Ein grosser Schritt.)
Für mich, für meine Kinder ...
Die Situation ist gut.
Hier gibt es keine Probleme
mit dem Krieg.
Kein Krieg.
- Kein Krieg.
(Als ich sie
vor drei Jahren kennenlernte,
war Vali noch ganz klein.)
(Haleema ist schwanger geflüchtet.)
(Der Junge
ist im Spital Einsiedeln geboren.)
(Im Durchgangszentrum habe ich mich
Haleema als Babysitterin angedient.)
(Ich hatte Zeit -
und Unterstützung auch.)
* Beschwingte Musik *
* Kindergeschrei *
* Kindergeschrei, Stimmengewirr *
Speak softly, okay? Tschau.
(Später haben mich Azimis
zum Abendessen eingeladen.)
(Mohammad war in Afghanistan Chine-
sich-Übersetzer, Haleema Lehrerin.)
(Geflüchtet sind sie
vor dem Terror.)
But this is Afghan Food.
Es gibt typisch afghanisches Essen.
Reis, Poulet, Pudding.
Pudding?
- Yes.
And these vegetables.
Halt nur etwas ganz Einfaches.
Sie müssen entschuldigen.
(Azimis redeten nur Englisch,
besuchten aber wie alle Bewohner
den Deutschunterricht.)
* Fröhliche Musik *
Was ist das?
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
- Ja.
Am Anfang ein Grossbuchstabe.
(Auch die Kleinen
besuchten die Schule.)
(Muska war vier Jahre alt,
hier links im Bild.)
# ...da seid, im Biberhof.
# Im Biberhof.
Gehen wir?
- Ja.
Freust du dich?
(Heute besucht Muska in Unteriberg
den grossen Kindergarten.)
Oh, Achtung! Achtung!
Autos ...
Sie ist ihre beste Freundin.
Deine beste Freundin?
- (Muska) Ja.
Wie heisst sie?
Jenny?
* Beschwingte Musik *
(Mehrere)
Fünf, sächs, siebä, acht.
Üse Chräis isch fertig gmacht.
Siehst du mein Loch?
Oh!
(Heute findet der Kindergarten
im Wald statt.)
* Lautes Kreischen *
(Im Sommer kommt Muska in die Schule
und sie hat ein klares Ziel.)
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Nach der neunten Klasse
habe ich alle Klassen fertiggemacht.
Dann will ich Doktor werden.
Warum willst du das?
- Weil es mir gefällt.
Und ich will zur Polizei.
* Mona lacht. *
Sie will ...
Ihre Mama sagt,
sie wolle eine Putzfrau sein.
Putzfrau? Nein, Polizistin. Oder?
- Ja.
(Die Lehrerin erzählt mir,
Muska habe sich gut integriert.)
(Die Eltern würden einen
wesentlichen Teil dazu beitragen.)
Sie bemüht sich auch sehr,
uns zu verstehen.
Das merkst du ...
Wenn ich einen Brief mitgebe,
fragen sie nach,
wenn sie es nicht verstehen.
Sie arbeiten viel
mit dem Google-Übersetzer.
Sie wollen wissen, was ich meine.
Muska spricht
schon recht gut Deutsch.
Wahnsinn, oder?
- Ja.
Wirklich. Sie hat
extrem Fortschritte gemacht,
auch die letzten paar Monate.
Die Frage ist, wie es weitergeht.
Ob sie hier bleiben
oder ob sie irgendwann weggehen
müssen. Das weiss man nie.
Aber wenn man sie jetzt
hier gedeihen lässt,
kommt das total gut.
(Muska und ihre Familie
haben den Status F.)
(Ihr Asylgesuch ist abgelehnt,
trotzdem können sie
vorläufig bleiben.)
(Eine Rückkehr
sei zurzeit nicht zumutbar.)
(Ihre Situation
wird jedes Jahr neu beurteilt.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
Vogelzwitschern *
(In Schwyz gehen die Eltern täglich
3 Std. in den Deutschunterricht.)
(Frau) ... und auf die Verben
mit ver, be oder en am Anfang
Diese Verben ...
(Am Morgen Mohammad,
am Nachmittag Haleema.)
(1 1/2 Std. benötigen sie,
um mit dem ÖV hierherzukommen.)
... können Sie mir das sagen?
"Diese Übung
habe ich nicht verstanden."
(Lehrerin) Gut.
"Was ist los?
Was ist denn passiert?"
(Lehrerin) Genau, gut.
Jetzt seid ihr bereits
drei Jahre in der Schweiz.
Du hast schon gut Deutsch gelernt.
Bist du manchmal ungeduldig?
Ja, immer noch. Ja.
Ich will arbeiten.
Ich will mein Geld haben -
und nicht von der Schweiz.
Ja.
- Ja.
Ist es schwierig?
Ihr hattet in Afghanistan ...
Dein Mann hatte eine gute Arbeit
als Dolmetscher
und du bist Lehrerin.
- Ja.
Das ist so schwer.
Wir müssen bei Null anfangen.
Ich möchte ...
Mein Mann könnte am Tag arbeiten
und ich nachts.
Oh, okay.
- Ja.
Damit immer jemand
bei den Kindern sein kann. - Ja.
Nachts arbeiten. - Ja.
- Okay.
Muska hat viele Wörter ...
Jeden Tag wenn sie
aus dem Kindergarten kommt,
bringt sie neue Wörter mit.
- Ja.
(Eine passende Arbeit in Unteriberg
zu finden, sei nicht einfach,
sagt Haleema.)
(Ohne Auto und mit
zwei kleinen Kindern zu Hause.)
(Für Azimis ist klar,
geschenkt wird einem nichts,
wenn man es in der Schweiz
schaffen will.)
(Sie hoffen,
dass ihnen jemand eine Chance gibt.)
* Lockere Musik, Kinderstimmen *
Als wir uns kennenlernten,
hast du ein Kopftuch getragen.
Jetzt nicht mehr. Warum?
Ich habe gemerkt, dass viele Leute
das Kopftuch nicht mögen.
Sie haben auf dein Kopftuch
reagiert?  - Ja.
Und da sagte ich mir: "Wenn wir
in der Schweiz bleiben wollen,
lasse ich es besser weg."
- Okay.
Habt ihr miteinander diskutiert?
Nein, diskutiert ...
* Er sucht nach den rechten Worten. *
Ich sagte Haleema ...
Es ist eine ...
... anpassen.
- An die Kultur anpassen.
Das ist möglich.
Merkst du, dass die Leute
anders reagieren, ohne Kopftuch?
Jetzt ist es normal.
Mit Kopftuch
waren alle etwas schockiert.
Aber jetzt ist es normal.
Ja.
- Ja.
Mami ...
* Sie flüstern. *
(Sich anpassen, integrieren.)
(Haleema und Mohammad Azimi
machen viel dafür,
damit ihre Kinder nach der Flucht
ein normales Leben führen können
und vielleicht in der Schweiz
eine zweite Heimat finden.)
Entschuldigung, das ging vergessen.
* Mohammad lacht, Vali schreit. *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
(Von Unteriberg
nach Freienbach am Zürichsee.)
(Hier lebt jetzt
Sabeha aus dem Irak.)
(Im Durchgangszentrum Biberbrugg
wohnte ich mit ihr im Zimmer.)
(Sie hat Flüchtlingsstatus B
erhalten.)
(Sie kann sicher
in der Schweiz bleiben.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
... oder nicht?
Hast du selbst gemacht? - Ja.
- Oh, la la!
Ich habe
bis gestern Abend gearbeitet.
Gestern hast du bis in die Nacht ...
- Abend.
... bis am Abend hast du gearbeitet.
- Ja.
Habe ich auch gemacht.
Oh, was ist das?
- Milch.
Ah, Quark.
- Ja.
Etwas Arabisches.
Du machst alles selbst.
- Ja.
Das ist ...
Das ist nicht deine Wohnung?
Du bist nicht alleine?
Nein, fünf Frauen.
- Fünf Frauen?
Hier?
- Ja.
Eine Wohngemeinschaft,
alle zusammen. Okay.
Wir teilen die Küche.
- Die Küche teilt ihr euch zusammen.
Sabeha, es ist
ein wenig wie in Biberbrugg.
Man kann kaum mit dir reden,
du arbeitest immer.
Immer arbeiten.
- Ich arbeite gern.
(Schon im Asylzentrum
war Sabeha praktisch nonstop
am Putzen und Backen.)
* Treibende Musik *
This is from Syria?
(Um alles und alle
kümmerte sie sich.)
(Wirklich beinahe wie eine Mutter,
sogar für mich.)
* Sanfte Musik, Stimmengewirr *
(Aber ich lernte auch
eine andere Seite von ihr kennen,
eine nachdenkliche.)
Bist du mit deiner Familie hier?
Meine Familie ist alle ...
Ist deine Familie im Irak
oder hast du keine Familie?
Ist es schlimm für dich, alleine?
Entschuldigung.
Okay?
- Okay.
Entschuldigung.
- Nein, nein, okay.
Ich schaue zu den Kindern.
Das ist ein Vogel.
Ja.
- Das ist schön.
Machst du das für die Kinder?
- Für die Kinder hier.
Der Vogel ist noch nicht fertig.
Hier kommt ein Auge hin.
- Ja.
(Sabehas Verwandte sind in
alle Himmelsrichtungen verstreut.)
(Für sie war das
schwer auszuhalten.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(An dieser Situation
hat sich bis heute nichts geändert.)
(Sie ist die Einzige der Familie,
die in der Schweiz ist.)
Alle der Familie sind in Schweden.
Ich bin immer alleine hier.
- Ja.
Es ist schwierig.
- Es ist schwierig.
"Es ist schwierig", sagt Sabeha
und lacht trotzdem.
Sie lacht trotzdem.
- ... gratis lacht.
* Mona lacht schallend. *
Gratis lachen, genau, aber schön.
Das ist super.
* Sanfte Musik,
Lachen im Hintergrund *
Grüezi!
- Grüezi, Frau Odeesho.
(Ein wichtiger Mensch in ihrem Leben
ist Deniz Ökmen.)
(Er ist ihr Betreuer
vom Sozialzentrum der Gemeinde.)
... hause oder nicht ...
Heute habe ich einige Sachen dabei.
Das ist für Sie.
Sie sprechen ja Arabisch.
Was ist das?
- Das ist nicht Arabisch.
Gesundheitsförderung.
Wie funktioniert die Schweiz?
Krankenkassen
und Sozialversicherungen.
Das ist nicht Arabisch.
Ah, das wäre Arabisch. - Ja.
- Die können Sie mir zurückgeben.
Sabeha und ich ...
(Deniz Ökmen ist einer
der wenigen Vertrauten Sabehas.)
(Er kennt auch ihre Geschichte.)
Sie hat mir auch erzählt, dass ihre
Verwandten, ihre Familie in Amerika,
aber v.a. in Schweden sind.
Sie ist die Einzige,
die in der Schweiz ist.
Sie ist ein Resettlement-Flüchtling.
Also von einem Kontingent.
- Genau, genau.
Durch das UNHCR
ist sie in die Schweiz gekommen.
D.h, dass sie vor Ort wahrscheinlich
all die Unterlagen eingereicht hat.
Dann wurde das quasi angenommen
oder akzeptiert.
"Du erfüllst
die Flüchtlingseigenschaften."
Wir im Sozialzentrum Höfen vermuten,
dass die Mitarbeiter vom UNHCR
einen Fehler gemacht haben.
Wir vermuten, sie haben Schweden
und Schweiz verwechselt,
aber wir wissen es nicht.
Resettlement-Flüchtlinge
dürfen normalerweise zu Eltern
oder Verwandten gehen,
dorthin, wo diese wohnen.
Bei ihr
ist etwas Komisches passiert.
Das ist unsere Vermutung. Schweiz
und Schweden wurden verwechselt.
Boah!
- Das kann gut möglich sein.
(Wenn das wirklich so ist:
ein kleiner Fehler, der für Sabehas
Leben unglaubliche Folgen hat.)
Wir können das
nicht rückgängig machen.
Das entscheidet das UNHCR,
da haben wir keinen Einfluss.
Man kann nicht fragen, warum Sabeha
nicht nach Schweden kann?
Nein, leider nicht.
- Ja, ah.
(Das UNHCR sagt auf Nachfrage,
so ein Fehler sei nicht möglich.)
Okay, trinken wir Tee.
... trinken Tee.
(Der Entscheid
sei von vielen Dingen abhängig.)
(Die Familie sei nur ein Kriterium.
Es bleibt ein Rätsel.)
Vielen Dank!
* Sie singt auf arabisch. *
Vielen Dank.
- Bitte.
Ich habe zwei Wörter verstanden.
- Was?
Chai und Augen, eye.
(Ein bisschen Glück hatte Sabeha
trotzdem - mit Deniz Ökmen.)
(Er kam selber als Flüchtling
in die Schweiz.)
(Vor zwölf Jahren, ohne Eltern,
ganz alleine.)
(Später studierte der junge Kurde
und beschäftigte sich intensiv
mit Flüchtlingsgeschichten.)
Jede Flucht
hat eine Tragödie hinter sich.
Sie ist ein bisschen
mit einem Trauma verbunden.
Man braucht so viel Zeit,
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Mehrere Jahre.
Also ist Geduld
eigentlich etwas Zentrales?
Geduld zu haben, bis die Leute
wirklich richtig angekommen sind.
Genau.
- Ja.
Geduld ist wirklich sehr wichtig.
Mhm.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Um weitergehen zu können,
muss man zuerst richtig ankommen.)
(Ich habe grossen Respekt
vor jedem einzelnen,
der seinen Weg hier macht.)
(Allen Hürden zum Trotz.)
(Meine zweite Zimmernachbarin
wurde der Gemeinde Brunnen
zugeteilt.)
(In einer kleinen Wohnung,
direkt an den Gleisen der Gotthard-
linie, lebt Hind aus Syrien.)
(Zusammen mit ihrem Neffen,
den sie dank der Flucht
vor dem Einzug in die Kriegstruppen
gerettet hat.)
(Heute ist er 16
und im Moment in der Schule.)
Da klemmt etwas.
Das kommt nicht mehr raus.
Was machen wir jetzt? Ah, super!
Wie geht es dir jetzt?
Gut, sehr gut.
Besonders in diesem Jahr.
Ja, sicher? - Ja.
- Erzähl!
Ich habe neue Freundinnen,
Schweizerinnen als Freudinnen.
Im Moment bereite ich mich
auf die Prüfungen vor.
Prüfungen? Deutschprüfungen?
- Ja, für Deutsch.
(Immer am Lernen.)
(So erlebte ich Hind
schon im Biberhof.)
(An der Uni in Aleppo
war sie Französisch-Übersetzerin.)
(Die Momente, in denen Hind
wirklich Ruhe hatte, waren rar)
* Stimmengewirr *
... Duvetanzug.
Gute Nacht!
- Tschüss! Bye!
(Privatsphäre gibt es kaum in
einem Viererzimmer auf knapp 30 m2,
wo man Tag und Nacht
aufeinander sitzt.)
(15 lange Monate war sie hier.)
Ich hoffe, die Schweiz
wird meine zweite Heimat.
Aber ich würde mir schon wünschen,
dass ich irgendwann einmal
zurück nach Syrien darf.
Wenn der Krieg vorbei ist,
wenn sich das Regime geändert hat.
Oh, that's good.
So this is a holiday for you.
(Kämpfen und durchbeissen.)
(Das musste Hind wegen ihrer
Kinderlähmung schon früh lernen.)
(Unseren Film über das Asylzentrum
hat sie noch nicht angeschaut.)
(Ganz bewusst, sie schaue
lieber vorwärts als zurück.)
Für mich war dieses Viererzimmer
mit drei fremden Frauen
ein Schock - so nahe zusammen.
Ich war drei Tage da, aber du warst
ein Jahr und drei Monate da.
Ja, ein Jahr und drei Monate.
- Wahnsinn.
Das war sehr schwierig.
Die Menschen, die Traditionen,
die Länder.
Du hast sehr schnell Deutsch
gelernt. - Ja, ziemlich.
Hast du so viel gearbeitet?
Nein, ich habe ehrenamtlich
im Altersheim gearbeitet.
Ich habe den alten Leuten
beim Essen geholfen.
Und wenn das Wetter gut war,
sind wir zusammen
spazieren gegangen.
War es eine gute Arbeit?
Leider war diese Arbeit
nicht für mich geeignet.
Warum nicht?
Das brauchte ...
... eine ...
... force corporelle.
- Ah, körperliche Kraft.
Das war wegen deiner Kinderlähmung
nicht geeignet ... - Ja, genau.
Du konntest z.B.
die Leute nicht stützen.  - Ja.
Jetzt kannst du das
nicht mehr machen.
Was hast du für Ziele?
Du möchtest arbeiten.
- Ja.
Ich möchte gerne
eine Büroarbeit finden.
(Auch Hind aus Syrien
hat den Status F.)
(Kein Asyl,
aber vorläufig aufgenommen.)
(Damit es mit einem Job bald klappt,
wird sie vom Amt für Migration
in Schwyz unterstützt.)
Vielen Dank.
Gut, Frau Hind.
Es gibt einen sog. Bürofachkurs.
Das nennt sich Handelsdiplom.
Er würde schon bald beginnen.
Er ist relativ streng.
Sie sind dazu bereit?
- Ja, ich bin bereit.
Die Arbeit ist Wünde ...
Eine Würde.
- Würde, ja genau.
Spürst du das,
wenn du keine Arbeit hast?
Hast du dann das Gefühl,
nichts wert zu sein?
Ja, genau.
(Ein Job ist für Asylbewerber mit
Status F auch darum so wichtig:
Wer eine fixe Anstellung hat
und finanziell unabhängig ist,
kann eine permanente
Aufenthaltsbewilligung beantragen.)
Die meisten, die ich getroffen habe,
habe den Status F.
"Immer wieder ein Jahr
darfst du bleiben."
Was heisst es, wenn man
mit Status F eine Arbeit sucht,
eine Ausbildung macht?
Im Grunde genommen
ist es ein paradoxer Status.
Es ist paradox.
Einerseits sagt man:
"Ihr müsst euch integrieren."
Andererseits sollten sie
aber nicht hier sein.
Wenn ich ein Arbeitgeber wäre
und in jemanden investieren möchte,
würde ich niemanden nehmen,
der in einem Jahr wieder weg ist.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist relativ klein.
90 % mit Status F ...
* Er räuspert sich. *
... bleiben dauerhaft
in der Schweiz.
(Der Einsatz von Hind
zahlt sich hoffentlich bald aus.)
(Auch sie hofft,
dass ihr jemand eine Chance gibt.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
Vogelzwitschern *
(Als Asylbewerber in der Schweiz
braucht man einen langen Atem,
um sich ein neues Leben aufzubauen.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
Vogelzwitschern *
(Die Basis
wird im Asylzentrum gelegt.)
(Da lernt man Schweizer Tugenden
wie Pünktlichkeit und Ordnung.)
(Punkt 8 Uhr:
Antreten zur Putzschicht.)
(Wer zu spät kommt, dem werden
3 Fr. abgezogen. Toleranz: Null.)
(Mann) Mona Vetsch.
- Ja, hier.
Jetzt sehe ich Sie. Sehr gut.
(Frau) Das Reinigungsmittel
gebe ich in den Eimer.
Wenn ich es nicht dosiere,
wenden sie es am liebsten pur an
und sie nehmen auch so wenig Wasser.
So kann ich kontrollieren, ob sie
den Eimer wieder gefüllt haben
und ob genügend Wasser drin ist.
(Frau Dubach hatte klare Regeln.)
(Aber sie machte die Rechnung
ohne Sabeha.)
(Ihr Credo:
mehr Schaum gleich mehr Sauberkeit.)
Nein! Sie macht illegales Zeug.
No, no to clean ...
Aber wenn Frau Dubach ...
Frau Dubach hat immer ...
Wenn sie das sieht,
dann bekommen wir beide ...
Was hat sie mir da hineingeschüttet?
(Meistens hatte ich
mit Samsom Putzschicht.)
(Er kommt aus Eritrea.)
You're here for how many months?
Nine.
- Neun Monate bist du schon hier?
Warum bist du so lange hier?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wie alt bist du?
- Ich bin 17 Jahre alt.
Ah, okay. Ja.
Und du bist ganz allein?
Ja, ich bin allein.
Wie ist es, wenn man mit
so vielen Leuten auf einem Boot ist?
500 Personen oder so.
Mhm.
So viele?
- Ja, so viele.
Man kann sich kaum bewegen.
Hatte es hohe Wellen?
Nein, das ist sehr schwierig.
(Die Überfahrt
hätten nicht alle überlebt.)
("Lieber nicht mehr daran denken",
war seine Strategie.)
(Wichtig sei die Zukunft.)
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Und die Zukunft brachte Samsom
vom Durchgangszentrum Biberbrugg
nach Pfäffikon/SZ,
in eine Wohngemeinschaft,
direkt an der Autobahn.)
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Samsom ist jetzt 20
und geht zur Schule.)
(Er macht ein Integrations-
brückenangebot mit Praktikum.)
(Seine WG-Mitbewohner sind im
Deutschunterricht oder am Arbeiten.)
* Wasser *
Wie viele Leute seid ihr insgesamt?
- Sieben Personen.
Sieben Personen.
- Ja.
Bist du der einzige aus Eritrea?
Wie redet ihr miteinander?
Welche Sprache? - Deutsch.
Das ist super!
- Das ist sehr gut.
* Mona lacht. *
Das kenne ich sehr gut -
vom Biberhof.
Von wem haben wir das gelernt?
- Frau Dubach.
Frau Dubach.
Und der Eimer ist auch da.
Ei, ei, ei!
Im Biberhof haben wir viel geputzt.
- Ja, ja.
Was hast du sonst gelernt
und vom Biberhof mitgenommen?
Pünktlich zu sein.
Wenn man nicht pünktlich ist,
wird einem Geld abgezogen.
1 Min. zu spät war schon ...
- Ja, schon zu spät.
Schon fertig,
das gibt schon weniger Geld.
Ja.
- Ja.
Heute merkst du,
dass das in der Schweiz wichtig ist?
Vorher sagte ich:
"Was ist schon 1 Min.?"
"Wegen 1 Min. spricht mich
Frau Dubach immer an."
Das habe ich so gesagt.
Jetzt habe ich gemerkt, dass es
sehr wichtig ist, pünktlich zu sein.
Das ist mein Zimmer.
Da wohne ich allein.
Das ist mein Pult,
hier lerne ich.
Hier lernst du?
- Ja.
Du hast noch keinen Tisch.
Du hast vier Tage Schule und
einen Tag Praktikum, also Arbeit.
Ja, momentan arbeite ich
nur einen Tag - am Mittwoch.
Aber ab Februar kann ich
zwei Tage arbeiten gehen.
Ich habe die Lehrstelle erhalten.
Du hast eine Lehrstelle erhalten?
- Ja.
Wow, eine Lehrstelle!
War das dein Traum?
Ja, das war mein Traum.
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Als einer der wenigen seiner Klasse
hat er es geschafft.)
(Samsom kann ab dem Sommer eine
Lehre als Automechaniker machen.)
* Pulsierende Musik *
Und deiner Familie in Eritrea ...
Ja.
- ... hast du davon erzählt?
Noch nicht.
- Noch nicht?
Ich telefoniere
alle sechs Monate oder so.
Nur so wenig?
Ja, wegen des Internets.
Das funktioniert nicht so oft.
Was werden sie sagen,
wenn du ihnen erzählst,
dass du eine Lehrstelle hast?
Ich glaube, sie verstehen das nicht.
Wenn ich sage, ich gehe arbeiten,
dann verstehen sie das ein bisschen.
Aber Lehrstelle: "Was ist das?"
Ich verstand den Unterschied
zwischen Lehre und Praktikum nicht.
Warum macht man zwei Jahre
eine Lehre?
Du hast gedacht,
dass man einfach Arbeit braucht.
Ja.
- Okay.
In Eritrea gibt es das nicht.
Man konnte einfach arbeiten.
Bist du gut
in der Schweiz angekommen?
Fühlst du dich in der Schweiz
schon ein bisschen zu Hause?
Jetzt ist es schon viel besser.
Am Anfang hatte ich ein bisschen ...
Man fühlt sich nicht wohl,
weil wir hier alleine sind.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Das war ein bisschen schwierig.
Jetzt fühle ich mich
ein wenig wie zu Hause.
* Lockere Schlagzeugmusik *
(Sein Praktikum macht Samsom
in dieser Garage in Freienbach.)
Hier macht er nachher
auch seine Lehre.)
Hoi, Alessandro.
- Hoi.
Morgen.
(Mann) Guten Morgen.
Geht es gut?
- Ja, dir?
Hallo.
Du kannst die Vorderpneus wegnehmen,
die Bremsen auseinandernehmen.
(Ein richtiger Ausbildungsplatz:
Das ist gut für Samsom,
aber auch für unsere Gesellschaft.)
(Integration laufe auch
über die Arbeit, findet sein Chef,
Ruedi Oberlin.)
Wenn wir die Leute schon hier haben
und sie wahrscheinlich bleiben,
sollten wir sie möglichst
schnell integrieren und versuchen,
ihnen Arbeit zu geben,
damit sie eine Beschäftigung haben.
Gab es im Vorfeld Unterschiede
gegenüber anderen Lernenden,
als Sie ihn
als Lernenden ausgesucht hatten?
War es schwieriger,
weil er den Status F hat?
Nein, für uns
spielte das keine Rolle.
Er hat seinen Betreuer dabei,
der ihn unterstützt - und uns auch.
Es geht auch darum,
wohin der Lohn geht, den er erhält,
und auch in Sachen
Unfallversicherung
ist es anders
als bei einem Schweizer.
Aber wir sind auch vom Kanton
gut unterstützt worden. - Ja.
D.h., für ein Unternehmen
ist es nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert,
diesen Menschen Arbeit zu geben?
- Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wie schätzen Sie Samsom ein?
Er hat eine
sehr gute Auffassungsgabe.
Er lernt sehr schnell
und er will auch.
Man merkt, dass er interessiert ist.
Wir werden uns Mühe geben,
der Rest wird an ihm liegen.
(Es braucht viel Willen und Eigen-
initiative, aber auch etwas Glück.)
(Das wünsche ich ihnen: Samsom,
Sabeha,
Hind und Familie Azimi.)
(Ein wenig Glück -
auf dem nicht ganz einfachen Weg,
um in der Schweiz
Fuss fassen zu können.)